the Joe Rogan experience you know I I
smoke pretty regularly but um I got high
would be real I did a this smoke box
show like okay I'm gonna be real or at
Cypress Hill I was ever still ecologist
I'm real I just you know I know nothing
about hip-hop damn
I do not know anything about Cypress
Hill I know I know people are always
like you gotta you know my above I'm
like I know [ __ ] I know Run DMC you
really don't know any hip-hop now I kind
of stopped after the Bohemian phase hmm
you know like after Tribe Called Quest
and until I saw like it just kind of
lost me because it didn't turn in
I like gangster in the beginning you
know because it was something new and
you're like what the [ __ ] is this oh
that's so cool you know but then it kind
of morphed in the club hop where it just
was all about [ __ ] and cars and all
that [ __ ] and it was really the lyrics
the beats I loved I thought it was cool
but I was like nervous I mean I because
I left in 95 in 95 96 and then I know
there's plenty of hip-hop heads I'll be
like dude you got check out so you got
check out I know there's shitloads of
[ __ ] and I maybe I'll go back into that
phase but mostly I just like the beats
and the production and the lyrics I'm
not really I'm not I'm not lyrics guy
anyways I am a lyrics guy and NAS is
definitely my favorite lyricist cuz his
stuff is so creative like what was that
one we did everything backwards to the
whole song backwards like he started at
the end and then the [ __ ] was I called
James gonna cool it rewind yeah I mean I
mean major look Rihanna yeah it made you
look like I saw that and I was like that
was actually a moment where I was like
how am I gonna am I gonna start getting
back into the [ __ ] cuz yeah because it
was intelligent yeah
you know what I mean like my thing is
like if you're gonna be boastful that
[ __ ] it should be like Muhammad Ali
right right right
you super clever clever flair also you
can just be right in someone's face but
I like that but then when people are
like kind of going off about how much
money they have and I'm like I don't
really care about this well I analyzed
this many times while under the
influence and the culture comes from not
having something and then once you have
something brag about it right like
that's like jay-z like that's 99
problems he talks about that 99 problems
yeah even I get it I get it but like at
the same time if
if it just sounds like basically the
three things that everyone talks about
which is like women cars of some sort
and money or the things you can buy with
money after a while it just all bleeds
together it's only it's the same song
and I mean that's so dope that you can
come from nothing and you can work your
way up and you can hustle and you can
get stuff going but like once you get to
that place like why not take advantage
of that place what about running the
jewels
I've heard good things about it yes the
rapper I've heard good things about it
Dan I know I don't know [ __ ] man I'm
more of like I'm the jewels of so cream
an electronic guy I like yeah let me
turn you on some run the jewels
[Applause]